he's Bryan Cranston known for Breaking
Bad malcolm in the middle' a lot of
other movies Broadway he's done at all
he's on Broadway now with Network and
one of the great actors of our
generation or any generation for that
matter and he's done pretty well in the
bracket challenge right now in fourth
place 7 points behind the legendary Jim
Parsons in the lead Brian good morning
legendary already yes he's one yep
yes he had I mean he's Jim Parsons I
mean he's a legendary no actor well yeah
and a really good guy but I can tell you
something you know he's going to hear a
big bang his rearview beer is this more
of your focus than being on Broadway I'm
gonna win this damn thing now Fritzi
Fritzi told me that I'm in fourth place
in the Parsons currently in first place
yeah but I have obviously there's two
other people that I have to climb over
before I conquer Parsons right and
there's Kevin Frazier from Entertainment
Tonight and and then we have a we opened
it up to fans we've allowed five fans to
be in the bracket town so one of our
fans is in third place right and then
it's you come on
would you rather win this or a Tony I
have a Tony already know I'm by the way
JP yeah what is the actual prize what AM
what am I going to receive street cred
why why do all your why do all of you
actors need something Jim Parsons said
the same thing he wants a trophy because
we're incredibly insecure needy Pauly
I'm gonna commission a trophy to be made
if you could make up a trophy
that's it out all right see what we can
do what was your game plan on filling
out your brackets you have North
Carolina winning the championship over
Michigan State I do I do I think that's
the the two strongest teams I looked a
lot at their defense I looked at who is
holding the other team down to me that
that's always been the key I also look
at assists who what team passes that
ball around a lot
who is the scoring spread around I mean
obviously if you have a superstar in
your team you gotta feed them but that's
what I look for I look for those things
that most people are not looking for the
splashing I go the other way
I think defense is one of the most
important things that we all know that
what kind of athlete were you in high
school I was incredibly mediocre okay
I know I I was okay I could hold my own
I would play football and baseball and
some basketball but I I just never put
forth the effort I didn't know that
there was a work reward situation so I
would mess around during practices and
things and and consequently I would find
myself either on the bench and then I
get I get discouraged and then quit the
team and it was it was a bad time for me
I wouldn't live my high school years for
anything
he's Bryan Cranston the actor and the
great bracket challenge entry here
fourth right now behind the legendary
Jim Parsons in our celebrity bracket
challenge yeah I'm so sick and tired of
hearing that what are you watching on TV
now watching on TV
aside from bascomb really watch yeah I
watched basketball and and watching
sports
I mean I'm um it's kind of a relief for
me because I'm working on Broadway now
it's kind of demanding so I get
exhausted and I don't want to go out too
much so I come home and and when my wife
is around I can't watch too much you
know
have to spend time and you know engaged
I've been married for 30 years you know
what it's like so it's then that's great
but it's like when I really want to veg
out I just pop on some some NBA but oh
man I'm a la Homer you know and and my
hockey team is doing terrible my
basketball team is doing terrible it's
like I'm waiting for baseball to start
and you're rams lost in the Super Bowl
my Rams lost yeah yeah yeah - you know I
know you guys were talking about what to
do about that the flagrant the non call
yeah in football and I looked at that
that was a terrible call I mean I feel
for Sean Payton boy that was that wasn't
that was a rough thing to accept and I
know that if I were a Saints fan I'd be
really upset about that and I don't know
what can happen now but nothing but you
know one of the I don't know who was
there was RIT here
McLovin or someone posted an idea that
what if the coach can have one call to
review an on call one flag that allows
them per game to review an on call and
then the coaches get together they'll
you know back in New York they'll look
at the tape and then they make make a
determination if there should have been
a call but you only get one per game so
you have to be very careful how you use
it yeah I'm okay with that I just I it
feels like every play is gonna be
subject to review or the possibility of
review and I just don't know how much is
too much and how much is not enough and
and I think that's what the NFL and plus
with the whole gambling aspect here
Brian like these plays are even more
important and the integrity even more
important of getting it right than it
used to be so the stakes are extremely
high for whatever rule they come up with
here a modification to this rule going
into next season I'm surprised that you
even brought up the fact that you're a
degenerate gambler
used to be bankrupt Razavi used to be
degenerate gambler did you ever gamble
on sport yeah yeah yeah I did and I
still do um if I'm in Vegas I'll go to
the sports book and and throw down a
huge mods of something before a season
and something like that I you know and
sometimes I'll go to the racetrack and
play some horses or something I had just
fun but nothing you know I can walk away
from I don't have any addiction problems
I don't when do you snap into character
when you get to Broadway or even when
you were doing Breaking Bad or Malcolm
in whatever it is like at what point do
you all of a sudden become that
character I there's a process for every
actor that you you go through for your
warm-up exercises I I I walk to the
theater I get there early I kind of
settle in to the theater and and you
know how what wouldn't you go to the gym
the moment you walk into the gym your
body starts reacting to it because it
knows what's going to happen at that
place the same thing with going to the
theater my body starts knowing what I'm
about to do for the next two hours on
stage and it kind of gets ready for it
and when you do it over and over and
over again your condition so it's almost
like an athletic event in that sense
that I know we would have done maybe a
hundred and forty performances of
network so far on Broadway this year and
and we will when we finish it'll be over
215 or so but it is like that and you
put yourself through that and an actor
has to go through emotionally and
physically intellectually and then
you're hyped up and then afterward you
you start coming down off the energy of
that and like a sporting event you then
realize on my arm Kirk I don't know I
did something to it or my
it's stiff or you don't know you know
when you go to the training room yeah I
go down and I sit after after a game you
know after I'm on stage I go to the
training room and ice down what happens
if you forget a line that happens you're
on stage with someone else who knows
that if you forgot a line or or messed
up the line and you try to cover for
each other it's it's a thing that there
there are no retakes on stage you have
to just go through it and that's part of
the excitement that you can make a
mistake and I'll relate it back to a
sporting event you know on a field or a
basketball court here you can and will
make mistakes you just have to own it
and figure out how to correct it in our
case we have to do it what is the
mistake going to confuse the audience do
we have to kind of restate something in
order for them to catch up to it or or
is it an acceptable pass and we can just
move on but I I take umbrage with that
that remark dad
suggesting that I would make a mistake
on stage that's I meant I married I
meant generically all of us actors so
was there you go it wasn't an indictment
on you I mean I'm just saying us actors
us thespians I doubt that I doubt the
legendary Jim Parsons would ever make a
mistake he's never made a mistake I'm so
sick and tired you know I'm gonna okay I
can't wait I made you know so far I'm
I'm in good shape
I thought that Wisconsin would actually
be up there a little longer I didn't
know Purdue would come in so strong I
really didn't I didn't but I missed that
one they played really strong defense
and you know I wouldn't be surprised if
they beat Tennessee how would Walter
White be in filling out a bracket
well it would all be about alchemy
wouldn't it you know would he would just
start start putting different he would
make a gaseous Purdue play against a
solid Tennessee and it comes out of
liquid he would he would infuse
chemistry with that I don't know how
good he would be he was pretty much of
an egghead so I don't I don't think he
has any I don't even know if he has any
awareness of bracketology at all but
it's a science and so he would be
slightly interested now yeah that's what
I thought I thought this last night I'm
like you know from a scientific
perspective you know that he was very
analytical where is you know when you
played how for Malcolm in the Middle
he was sort of oblivious to everything
so I don't know if how would have done
better because he had no clue where is
Walter White Maya might have thought I'm
smart enough to figure this out I think
a lot of time on my hands last night by
the way you know when you over it part
of filling out a bracket is not to over
think against I really believe that I
mean you start to if you break it down
too far and get into the microcosm of
all the ins and outs I think you get
yourself in trouble and you have to
allow some room for some upsets although
this year it's really kind of there
hasn't really been a Cinderella team has
anybody I mean Irvine winning that first
round but then they were knocked off and
no one's really carried on surprisingly
so no no it's been kind of a void of you
know if Central Florida had beaten Duke
then I think that would have you know
turned them upside down yeah I think
it's less interesting because there
hasn't been a Cinderella team
yes jump up and catch everybody
surprised yeah yeah I mean we're used to
one
you know Oregon I guess you can say a
Cinderella even though Oregon is a
big-time sports program but I I don't
know if we have that feel good we're
rooting for them or that's a cute story
we sort of like chaos until we get to
the Elite Eight and then we want restore
you know order restored there just so
you get a true national champion but you
know we we haven't had that and it just
feels like it's a little more
predictable than normal oh yeah but it
doesn't matter because right now Jim
Parsons the legendary Jim Parsons Oh
dominating dominating by the way
dominating slightly a seven buildings
behind well that's so I know what
what has he predicted in this next round
that that I could look at to root
against him and put all and hit I have a
Jim Parsons voodoo doll that I can poke
holes oh I want to see if I can jam him
up a little bit I'm gonna get some of my
best people on that by the way you're
dominating Will Ferrell if that matters
Will Ferrell is doing horribly well yeah
you know yeah it does it doesn't matter
it doesn't mean that it does mean
something to me thank you for that okay
okay hey keep your head up all right and
go see Brian if you can on Broadway in
network it's an incredible performance
do you have a movie that you're gonna be
working on what do you got coming up
after this ends I'm I'm gonna take a
break and then I'm gonna shoot a film
down in New Orleans and I'm gonna go
hold Sean Payton's hands and commiserate
with him I am I'm gonna shoot a film
down there starting in September and I
know I'll go to some of the games Sean's
a Breaking Bad fan and I I was on the
sidelines in that Stadium in the in the
Superdome down there and it was
incredible
I was it was unbelievable to hear that
that noise
on the sidelines I had yell to the
person I was with in order to be heard
you know it's so incredible it's really
fun to see a game there and I you know I
like the Saints I really kind of do you
yeah they didn't do anything to you yeah
no I like him yeah I like breathes and
I'd love to see him finish strong
that'd be fun well congrats on being in
fourth place behind the legendary Jim
Parsons and we wish you the best of luck
throughout the tournament and of course
did that say that one more time I'm
going to crawl through this phone line
and grab you by the throat fourth place
behind the legend dick you weren't
kidding watch watch what happens in the
next the next round here
thank you Brian uh that's a that's a
Brian Cranston
he's in net work on Broadway he takes
this very very seriously but he's still
trailing the legendary Jim for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]